Over the past 20 years, the field of positive psychology has grown from a fledgling idea to a worldwide movement. Positive psychology is the scientific study of the strengths that enable individuals and communities to thrive. It is based on the idea that psychological research can help us understand the characteristics and qualities that allow people to lead more meaningful and fulfilling lives, and then design techniques to help them do that. After a year when many of us have had a hard time staying optimistic, most of us would welcome any tips on how to become more positive. What does positive psychology have to say about flourishing in tough times, such as a pandemic?
在过去的20年里，积极心理学领域已经从一个萌芽中的想法发展成为一场全球性的运动。积极心理学是对使个人和社区能够茁壮成长的优势的科学研究。它基于这样一种理念：心理学研究可以帮助我们理解那些让人过上更有意义和更充实生活的特征和品质，并据此设计出帮助人们实现这一目标的方法。在许多人难以保持乐观的一年后，我们大多数人都很欢迎关于如何变得更积极的建议。积极心理学对于在疫情等困难时期如何蓬勃发展有什么见解呢？
And for people who are not optimistic by nature, is there anything they can do to become more positive? Does being positive offer particular benefits, such as perhaps greater resistance to viruses? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship. flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Martin Seligman, a professor of psychology at the University of Pennsylvania, and director of the Penn Positive Psychology Center. He's been called the founder of Positive Psychology and has published
对于天生不乐观的人来说，他们能做些什么来变得更积极吗？变得积极是否能提供特别的好处，比如可能增强对病毒的抵抗力？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学心理学教授、宾大积极心理学中心主任马丁·塞利格曼博士。他被称为积极心理学的创始人，并已发表了
more than 350 scholarly publications and 30 books, including his latest and autobiography, called the Hope Circuit, which you can find on Amazon. He was also president of the American Psychological Association in 1998, during which one of his presidential initiatives was the promotion of positive psychology as a field of scientific study. He is also a leading authority in the fields of resilience, learned helplessness, depression, optimism, and pessimism. And he is a recognized authority on interventions that prevent depression and build strengths and well-being.
超过350篇学术论文和30本书，包括他最新的自传《希望回路》（The Hope Circuit），你可以在亚马逊上找到。他还是1998年美国心理学会的主席，任职期间，他的总统倡议之一就是推动积极心理学作为一门科学研究领域的发展。他也是韧性、习得性无助、抑郁、乐观和悲观领域的权威专家。同时，他还是预防抑郁、建立优势和幸福感的干预措施方面的公认权威。
Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Seligman. Oh, thank you, Kim. Thanks for having me. Let's start with one of the questions I posed in the introduction. It's been more than a year since the SARS-CoV-2 virus was identified, and while vaccines are providing a good deal of hope, there's still a long winter ahead of us. What lessons can people take from positive psychology that they can use to get through the next few months?
欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，塞利格曼博士。哦，谢谢你，金。谢谢邀请我。让我们从我在介绍中提出的一个问题开始。距离SARS-CoV-2病毒被发现已经过去一年多了，虽然疫苗带来了很大的希望，但我们面前仍然有一个漫长的冬天。人们可以从积极心理学中汲取哪些经验来度过接下来的几个月呢？
Well, positive psychology has a lot to say about COVID and what we should be doing. And I should take him that I'm personally, this is quite a tale for me. We made the mistake of having Thanksgiving with all of our five kids. Good thing to do. We all got tested before. My son came in from Chicago. All of a sudden, he had it. Oh, no.
嗯，积极心理学对新冠疫情以及我们应该做什么有很多见解。我得告诉你，金，对我个人来说，这真是一个传奇故事。我们犯了一个错误，和我们的五个孩子一起过了感恩节。这本是件好事。我们事先都做了检测。我儿子从芝加哥赶来。突然之间，他感染了。哦，不。
And all five of my kids and my wife came down with COVID. whereupon they kicked me out of the house and I evacuated to a hotel for 17 days until they were past the period of recovery. And I just returned about a week ago. And I've been in quarantine since March 1st. And so COVID has been quite an experience for this family. And I expected to be going on through about the spring. So my task is to hold out until I can get the jab. I hope that'll be in March and then we can resume life.
结果我的五个孩子和我的妻子都感染了新冠。于是他们把我赶出了家门，我撤离到一家酒店住了17天，直到他们度过了恢复期。我大约一周前才回来。从3月1日开始我就一直在隔离。所以新冠对我们这个家庭来说真是一次特别的经历。我预计这种情况会持续到春天左右。所以我的任务是坚持到我能打上疫苗。我希望那会在三月份，然后我们就能恢复正常生活了。
But let me say what positive psychology has told us. And I think the science tells people about COVID. First, I think when one talks about positive psychology, it's important to make nuanced distinctions about different kinds of well-being. And the one I'm about to make is the difference between smiling, merry, cheerful, being happy, called positive, affective, and optimistic, forward-looking, which is not a feeling. It's a cognition about the future. It's about hope. Now, those are both positive, but they have different effects, particularly with respect to different illnesses.
但让我说说积极心理学告诉了我们什么。我认为科学告诉了人们关于新冠的什么。首先，我认为当谈论积极心理学时，对不同类型的幸福感做出细致的区分是很重要的。我接下来要做的区分是：微笑、快乐、欢呼、幸福（称为积极情感）与乐观、前瞻性（这不是一种感觉，而是一种关于未来的认知，即希望）之间的区别。现在，这两者都是积极的，但它们有不同的影响，特别是在针对不同疾病方面。
So there is a literature on protection from rhinovirus. A rhinovirus, as you know, is a coronavirus. It's the common cold virus. And Sheldon Cohen in Pittsburgh took a large number of volunteers, paid the meat $300, and put rhinoviruses in their nose, and then isolated them for two weeks and asked, could he predict who would get a cold and how severe it would be? And before they're isolated, he gives them a whole battery of tests, optimism, cheerfulness, positive emotion, negative emotion, and the like.
关于预防鼻病毒的文献确实存在。如你所知，鼻病毒是一种冠状病毒。它是普通感冒病毒。匹兹堡的谢尔顿·科恩招募了大量志愿者，付给他们300美元，把鼻病毒放进他们的鼻子里，然后将他们隔离两周，并询问他是否能预测谁会感冒以及感冒会有多严重？在他们被隔离之前，他给他们做了一整套测试，包括乐观、开朗、积极情绪、消极情绪等等。
The results are quite remarkable and they're substantial. First, interesting to me, since I've spent my life working on optimism, optimism had no effect on whether or not you get a cold and how long it left. The big effect was being cheerful, merry, high, positive, effective before the rhinovirus is put in the nose. Happy people, in the subjective well-being sense, got about half the colds, and they were shorter and less severe. And by the way, this was not about complaining since he actually weighed the mucus. So it's a rigorous, a rigorous measure of getting a cold. So the first lesson is during the pandemic, if you're in a situation like mine in which what you're trying to do for the next three months is just avoid getting it, in addition to wearing a mask and social distancing, you should have as much fun as you possibly can.
结果非常显著且具有实质性。首先，这对我来说很有趣，因为我一生都在研究乐观，但乐观对你是否感冒以及感冒持续多久没有任何影响。最大的影响是在鼻病毒进入鼻子之前是否开朗、快乐、具有高度积极的情感。在主观幸福感意义上快乐的人，感冒的几率大约只有一半，而且感冒时间更短，症状更轻。顺便说一句，这与抱怨无关，因为他实际上称量了粘液。所以这是一个衡量感冒的严谨指标。因此，第一个教训是，在疫情期间，如果你处于像我这样试图在接下来的三个月里尽量避免感染的情况下，除了戴口罩和保持社交距离外，你应该尽可能多地找乐子。
Now, of course, it's difficult in a pandemic to have a lot of fun. But let me tell you my advice and what we've done. First, we bought a puppy. And the puppy brought us until it's now 10 months old, enormous joy. Dancing, singing, sex, making love, good food, all the things that you can do in a pandemic in quarantine to have. have fun, even how difficult it is. So I have Zoom sessions with my students and we dance. And a lot of the positive psychology website people have created COVID exercises to have fun. So that's part one. The science tells us as hard as it is, have as much fun as you can.
当然，在疫情期间要找很多乐子是很困难的。但让我告诉你我的建议以及我们做了什么。首先，我们买了一只小狗。这只小狗直到现在10个月大，给我们带来了巨大的快乐。跳舞、唱歌、性生活、做爱、美食，所有这些你在疫情隔离期间可以做来找乐子的事情，尽管这很难。所以我通过Zoom和我的学生们开会，我们一起跳舞。许多积极心理学网站的人也创造了新冠期间的娱乐练习。所以这是第一部分。科学告诉我们，尽管很难，但要尽可能多地找乐子。
and that may indeed be a protective factor. Part two is the question, when this is over and this two will pass, what characteristics matter? Who recovers? Who is a better leader? Who is more productive? And there, the data are that being cheerful and merry doesn't do anything at all. It's being optimistic and hopeful.
这确实可能是一个保护因素。第二部分是这个问题：当这一切结束时，而且这一切终将过去，什么特征才重要？谁会恢复？谁是更好的领导者？谁更有效率？在这些方面，数据表明，开朗和快乐根本不起作用。起作用的是乐观和希望。
It's the people who interpret the future as they're going to be good events, bad events are going to fade, bad events are only just this one situation, and I can do something about it. These are the people who go on to be more productive, healthier, and better leaders. So the bottom line here is during the pandemic, have a great time as best you can. After the pandemic, and as it ends, it's hope and optimism that are going to predict recovery, leadership, and our future. That leads me to wonder a little bit about, you might call it stickiness. If people are not naturally optimistic, but they go through the actions of trying to behave in an optimistic way, does that?
正是那些将未来解读为会有好事发生、坏事会消退、坏事只是这一种情况、并且我可以做点什么的人，才会成为更有效率、更健康、更好的领导者。所以这里的底线是：在疫情期间，尽你所能享受美好时光。在疫情之后，随着它结束，预测恢复、领导力和我们未来的将是希望和乐观。这让我有点好奇，你可以称之为“粘性”。如果人们天生不乐观，但他们通过行动试图以乐观的方式行事，这会吗？
measurably change their personality. Can you learn to be optimistic if that's not your natural bent? Yeah. And I'm a good example of that. So I'm naturally a depressive and a pessimist. And I take my own medicine and everything I'm about to say, I do and my family does. So when we have a good idea about an intervention in positive psychology, I first do it on myself. If it works on me, I give it to my wife and seven children to do. If it works on them, I give it to my graduate students and postdocs, and we start to do outcome studies on it. So one thing we have learned is that pessimism is changeable. You can change it to optimism.
可衡量地改变他们的性格吗？如果这不是你的天性，你能学会乐观吗？是的。我就是一个很好的例子。我天生就是一个抑郁症患者和悲观主义者。我服用自己的药，我即将说的每一件事，我和我的家人都在做。所以当我们对积极心理学中的某种干预措施有了一个好主意时，我首先在自己身上做实验。如果它对我有效，我就让我的妻子和七个孩子去做。如果对他们有效，我就让我的研究生和博士后去做，然后我们开始对其进行结果研究。所以我们学到的一件事是，悲观是可以改变的。你可以把它变成乐观。
And the key to this is first tuning in to the most pessimistic. and the most catastrophic thoughts you say to yourself. And that's something people are pretty good at doing. It's the main move in cognitive behavioral therapy. And then having identified your most catastrophic thoughts, treat them as if they were said to you by someone whose mission in life was to make you miserable and argue rationally against them. So let me give you an example that I use, and I've used. used during this pandemic. So my first thought when I came back home after 17 days of isolation was, you know, this medical stuff
而关键在于首先要调频到你对自己说的最悲观、最灾难性的想法。这是人们非常擅长做的事情。这是认知行为疗法中的主要动作。然后，在识别出你最灾难性的想法后，把它们当作是一个人生使命就是让你痛苦的人对你说的，并理性地反驳它们。让我给你一个我在这次疫情期间使用过的例子。所以，在17天的隔离后回到家，我的第一个想法是，你知道，这些医疗的东西
is nonsense. They're still infectious. I'm going to be down with this in four days. And I'm 78 years old. So I'm dead. And the statistics are indeed that compared to the young population, I'm 222 times more likely to die. So that's my first thought, okay, my most catastrophic thought. And then I argued against it rationally.
都是胡扯。他们仍然具有传染性。我四天内就会倒下。而且我已经78岁了。所以我死定了。统计数据确实显示，与年轻群体相比，我死亡的可能性高出222倍。所以这是我的第一个想法，好吧，我最灾难性的想法。然后我理性地反驳了它。
So what I said to myself is called the put it in perspective exercise. That says first go through the most catastrophic scenario possible. Okay? I just did it. The second part is go through the least catastrophic. What's the best thing that could happen? And so I said to myself, well, the best thing that can happen is they're not infectious. And indeed, these two wonderful vaccines are out. And I'm going to be just fine. And I'll get a vaccine first thing in January. Okay. Then the third thing to do is having done the worst possible scenario and the best possible scenario, what's the most realistic scenario? Well, the most realistic scenario is I'm going to be very limited between now and the time a jab occurs. And I'm not going to get this in January. You know, the president and the vice president got it yesterday, but I'm not going to get it till the spring. So what I have to do is plan for the future.
所以我对自己说的是所谓的“换位思考练习”。首先要经历最灾难性的可能情景。好吧？我刚刚做到了。第二部分是经历最不灾难性的情景。可能发生的最好的事情是什么？所以我对自己说，嗯，可能发生的最好的事情是他们没有传染性。而且确实，这两种很棒的疫苗已经出来了。我会没事的。我会在一月份第一时间接种疫苗。好吧。然后第三件事是，在做完了最坏和最好的情景后，最现实的情景是什么？嗯，最现实的情景是，从现在到接种疫苗之前，我的活动将受到很大限制。而且我不会在一月份就打上疫苗。你知道，总统和副总统昨天打了，但我得等到春天。所以我必须为未来做计划。
I have to find a way to be at home most of the time to teach my classes and to minimize my exposure. So the most likely scenario is the next three months are going to be difficult and there is a pretty good chance if I'm careful I'll be able to avoid the infection. that's my early morning stuffiness. The catastrophic interpretation would be, there it is, I've got COVID. The most realistic explanation is early morning stuffiness. That's a good exercise that any one of our listeners could do and could benefit from. Let me change gears and talk a little bit about the effects of the pandemic on children and how disruptions to school and socializing and other life experiences may affect them in the long run. What kind of advice might you have for parents, educators, or others on how to help children's well-being right now? What can we do to help make them more optimistic?
我必须找到一种方法，大部分时间待在家里教课，并尽量减少接触。所以最可能的情景是接下来的三个月会很困难，如果我小心的话，我有很大机会避免感染。这就是我清晨的鼻塞。灾难性的解读会是：看吧，我感染新冠了。最现实的解释是清晨鼻塞。这是一个任何听众都可以做并从中受益的好练习。让我换个话题，谈谈疫情对儿童的影响，以及学校和社交的中断以及其他生活经历如何从长远上影响他们。对于父母、教育工作者或其他帮助儿童的人，你有什么建议来帮助他们现在的幸福感？我们能做些什么来帮助他们变得更乐观？
Well, the same things work with children as working with adults, and that is recognizing catastrophic thoughts and disputing them. But there's no doubt that a year away from, from school and away from friends is going to make things more difficult. And so there, it's optimism that's going to matter and what we do when we come out of a pandemic. But I think I want to say something general, Kim, about my view of the future given the pandemic. I think the world is in labor and something is being born and that we will learn from this pandemic. what to keep and what to throw away. But importantly, there are two views of children and our future, given this pandemic. I'm going to call it Yates versus Juliana. Yates, 100 years ago,
嗯，对儿童有效的方法和对成年人一样，那就是识别灾难性想法并反驳它们。但毫无疑问，远离学校和朋友一年会让事情变得更困难。所以，乐观精神将是重要的，以及我们在疫情结束后要做什么。但我认为我想说一些关于我对疫情下未来的普遍看法，金。我认为世界正在阵痛中，有什么东西正在诞生，我们将从这次疫情中学习到什么该保留，什么该抛弃。但重要的是，鉴于这次疫情，关于儿童和我们的未来有两种观点。我称之为“叶芝”与“朱利安”。叶芝，100年前，
in this poem about the troubled, asked what rough beast is slouching its way to Bethlehem now to be born? This is the pessimistic view that the labor that the world is in now is going to result in something worse than what we have. So the Yates view, highly pessimistic. And all you need to do is pick up the New York Times to hear the Yates view one way or another. Juliana of Norwich is the one I lean to. Juliana, as you may remember, was a monk. You had to take a male name to be a monk. She's called Julian of Norwich.
在他那首关于困境的诗中，问道：“是什么粗野的野兽，正蹒跚着向伯利恒走去，等待出生？”这是悲观的观点，认为世界现在所处的阵痛将导致比我们现在更糟糕的结果。所以叶芝的观点是非常悲观的。你只需要拿起《纽约时报》，就能以某种方式听到叶芝的观点。诺里奇的朱利安是我倾向的观点。朱利安，你可能记得，是一位修道士。你必须取一个男性名字才能成为修道士。她被称为诺里奇的朱利安。
And she wrote in the middle of the Black Plague. And by the way, the Black Plague is a hundred times worse than what we're going through now. Humans have gone through plagues for time immemorial. The Black Plague killed one third of the European population. There was no safety net at all. There was no zooming. And it was in many ways the worst of times. And Juliana Neoplatonist mystic wrote the following about what was being born.
她写于黑死病期间。顺便说一句，黑死病比我们现在经历的要严重一百倍。人类从远古时代起就经历过瘟疫。黑死病杀死了欧洲三分之一的人口。当时根本没有任何安全网。没有Zoom。在许多方面，那是“最糟糕的时代”。而新柏拉图主义神秘主义者朱利安写下了关于正在诞生之物的以下内容。
He said not, thou shalt not be travailed. He said not, thou shalt not be tempestiff. He said not, there shall not be diseased. He said, thou shalt not be overcome, and all shall be well, and all shall be well, and all manner of things shall be well. This is the dilemma we're in now about our future. Will there be a beast slouching its way to Bethlehem to be born to take over the world? or will all things be well? And for me, the Giuliana view and the Yates view are both self-fulfilling.
他说，不是，你不会受苦。他说，不是，你不会经历风暴。他说，不是，你不会生病。他说，你不会被战胜，一切都会好起来，一切都会好起来，各种各样的事情都会好起来。这就是我们现在关于未来的困境。会有一只野兽蹒跚着向伯利恒走去，准备接管世界吗？还是说一切都会好起来？对我来说，朱利安的观点和叶芝的观点都是自我实现的。
So what we need here is optimism, planning, and hope for the future. Let's talk for a moment about some of your earliest research into learned helplessness. You studied dogs and other mammals. And I'm wondering how in the intervening years you've changed your thinking around learned helplessness. and now you talk more about the idea of learned hopefulness. Can you explain for our listeners first what is meant by learned helplessness, which they might not be familiar with, and then tell us how and why you're thinking and research in this area evolved?
所以我们这里需要的是乐观、规划和对未来的希望。让我们谈谈你早期关于“习得性无助”的研究。你研究了狗和其他哺乳动物。我想知道在随后的几年里，你是如何改变对习得性无助的看法的，现在你更多地谈论“习得性希望”的概念。你能先为我们的听众解释一下什么是习得性无助吗？他们可能不太熟悉，然后告诉我们你的想法和研究在这个领域是如何演变的？
Yes, learned helplessness has been flipped on its head in the last 20 years. So 50 years ago, Steve Mayer and Bruce Overmire and I found that when animals and people experience bad events, that they couldn't do anything about that they collapsed and became passive and became helpless. And we called it learned helplessness. And what we found that people and animals who got the very same events, but they could do something about them, did not become helpless. Well, Steve Mayer went off and became a neuroscientist. And starting around 1990, 1995,
是的，习得性无助在过去20年里被彻底颠覆了。50年前，史蒂夫·迈耶、布鲁斯·奥弗迈尔和我发现，当动物和人经历他们无法做任何事情的坏事时，他们会崩溃、变得被动并变得无助。我们称之为“习得性无助”。我们发现，经历同样事件但能够做点什么的动物和人，并没有变得无助。嗯，史蒂夫·迈耶后来成为了一名神经科学家。从1990年、1995年左右开始，
we began to get pretty good tools for looking at the brain. And Steve wanted to know what was happening in the brain of rats when they became helpless. And the findings were astonishing. And they flipped the field on its head. What Steve found is that both in animals and human, there's a structure sort of up the nose. It's 50,000 cells in a rat and 150,000 cells. in a human called the dorsal rafé nucleus. And the dorsal rafay nucleus, its activity produces helplessness.
我们开始拥有相当好的工具来观察大脑。史蒂夫想知道当老鼠变得无助时，它们的大脑里发生了什么。研究结果令人震惊。它们颠覆了这个领域。史蒂夫发现，在动物和人类中，鼻腔上方有一种结构。在老鼠身上有5万个细胞，在人类身上有15万个细胞，叫做背侧中缝核。而背侧中缝核的活动会产生无助感。
It's necessary and sufficient for producing helplessness. Now very interesting, it turns out there is a circuit from up here in the forebrain, the medial frontal lobes. There's a specific circuit that goes down to the dorsal refrain nucleus. and turns it off. And it turns it off when you learn mastery, when you have hope. So it turns out that contrary to what we thought 50 years ago, and this is one of the great things about being in a science for 50 years,
它是产生无助感的必要且充分条件。现在非常有趣的是，事实证明，从这里的前脑，即内侧额叶，有一条回路。有一条特定的回路通向背侧中缝核，并将其关闭。当你学会掌控、当你拥有希望时，它就会关闭它。所以事实证明，与我们50年前的想法相反——这也是从事科学研究50年的伟大之处之一，
you can find out you're wrong. We found out we were wrong. Being helpless is the default mammalian reaction to troubles. were born helpless. The default reaction is to give up. What we have, however, what humans have is a circuit, which I call the hope circuit, which when it's ignited by mastery and hope turns off helplessness. So it turns out what's learned in helplessness experiments is hope and mastery,
你可以发现自己错了。我们发现我们错了。无助是哺乳动物面对麻烦时的默认反应。我们生来就是无助的。默认反应是放弃。然而，我们所拥有的，人类所拥有的，是一条回路，我称之为“希望回路”，当它被掌控感和希望点燃时，就会关闭无助感。所以事实证明，在无助实验中习得的是希望和掌控感，
and that's the protective factor. So it's a great story. and there was a lead article in the Psych Review a couple of years ago, which tells the whole story. And it's told in my book, The Hope Circuit. That's why I called it the Hope Circuit. You've described several eureka moments in your life that has led you to change the direction of your thinking and your research. One happened many years ago when you were gardening with your daughter, who was then five years old. And another came when you had an extraordinary dream that involved the Guggenheim Museum and a sort of celestial message you received. Could you talk about those incidents and how they influenced your work and your life?
而这才是保护因素。所以这是一个伟大的故事。几年前《心理学评论》上有一篇主导文章，讲述了整个故事。我的书《希望回路》中也讲述了它。这就是我称之为“希望回路”的原因。你描述了你生命中几个导致你改变思维和研究方向的“尤里卡时刻”。一个发生在多年前你和当时五岁的女儿在花园里的时候。另一个发生在你做了一个非凡的梦，涉及古根海姆博物馆和你收到的一种天启信息时。你能谈谈这些事件以及它们如何影响了你的工作和生活吗？
Yeah, I've been the fortunate recipient of at least two life-changing epiphanies. One occurred in what is called a numinous dream. And the other occurred in my garden right after I had been elected president of the American Psychological Association. So I'll narrate each of them, Kim. The dream one occurred about two weeks after quite an extraordinary lunch with my mentor, Aaron Beck. Tim is now 99 and a half years old. He and I still meet once a week.
是的，我至少是两次改变人生的顿悟的幸运接受者。一次发生在所谓的“神圣之梦”中。另一次发生在我被选为美国心理学会主席后不久，在我的花园里。所以我将分别讲述它们，金。梦的那一次发生在我与我的导师亚伦·贝克进行了一次非常非凡的午餐大约两周后。蒂姆现在99岁半了。我和他仍然每周见一次面。
He's in great shape mentally. And back then, this is now almost 50 years ago, we would have lunch once a week. week and he's a very kindly gentle soul. And 50 years ago, I was a tenured professor at Penn doing animal experimental psychology. And over lunch, Tim said, Marty, if you continue to do what you're doing, you're going to waste your life. And I kind of choked on my grilled Rubin and took it under advisement. And about two weeks later, I had the following dream. In this dream, and dreaming is something I've worked on much of my life.
他精神状态很好。那时，也就是将近50年前，我们每周吃一次午餐。他是一个非常善良、温柔的灵魂。50年前，我是宾大的一名终身教授，从事动物实验心理学。午餐时，蒂姆说：“马蒂，如果你继续做你现在做的事，你就是在浪费生命。”我当时差点被我的鲁宾三明治噎住，并把这话记在心里。大约两周后，我做了下面这个梦。在这个梦里——做梦是我一生中研究很多的事情。
And in fact, I think the best paper I ever wrote, which no one has read, is called What is a Dream? And for me, this nails the process of what dreaming is. But without going through the theory of dreaming, here was the dream. I'm walking up the ramp at the Guggenheim Museum, and I notice that on the right there are doors, and I open each of the doors, and there are people playing with cards. And I'm very puzzled about this. So I asked the question, why is everyone playing with cards, whereupon the roof of the Guggenheim opens and the godhead appears? And God, Kim, you'll be happy to hear, is an elderly male, look white beard, gray, with a booming voice. And God says to me, Seligman, at least you're starting to ask the right questions.
事实上，我认为我写过的最好的论文，虽然没人读过，叫做《什么是梦？》。对我来说，这揭示了做梦的过程。但如果不深入探讨做梦的理论，梦的内容是这样的：我正走在古根海姆博物馆的坡道上，我注意到右边有门，我打开每一扇门，里面有人在玩牌。我对此感到非常困惑。所以我问了一个问题：“为什么每个人都在玩牌？”随即古根海姆的屋顶打开了，上帝出现了。上帝，金，你会很高兴听到，是一位年长的男性，留着白胡子，灰色的，声音洪亮。上帝对我说：“塞利格曼，至少你开始问正确的问题了。”
And that changed my life, actually. So it's what moved me from being an experimental psychologist to a clinical psychologist. from a experimental researcher to a longitudinal researcher and from animals to humans. So it's a dream that moved me and has stayed with me. Fast forward now 30 years. I'm elected president of the American Psychological Association, and I'm told that presidents are supposed to have initiatives. and I didn't really know what mine was going to be.
这确实改变了我的生活。这就是让我从实验心理学家转变为临床心理学家的原因。从实验研究者转变为纵向研究者，从动物研究转变为人类研究。所以这是一个触动了我并一直伴随着我的梦。现在快进30年。我被选为美国心理学会主席，有人告诉我总统应该有倡议，但我真的不知道我的会是什么。
I've worked in a lot of different areas. And as I was mulling this, taking office, I was in my garden. I'm a gardener. And with my five-year-old daughter, Nikki. Nikki is now a clinical psychologist, by the way, getting her PhD from Fordham, doing her internship.
我在很多不同的领域工作过。当我上任时，我正在思考这个问题，我在我的花园里。我是一个园丁。和我五岁的女儿尼基在一起。顺便说一句，尼基现在是一名临床心理学家，正在福特汉姆大学攻读博士学位，正在实习。
but she founded positive psychology in the following way. She had just had her fifth birthday, about maybe two weeks before this incident in the garden. And we're in the garden together, and I'm weeding. And Nikki is having a great time. She's singing and dancing and throwing weeds in the air. And I yelled at her, and I said, get to work, Nikki, damn it. we're weeding. And Nikki walks away. And she comes back and says, Daddy, can I talk to you? And I said, sure, Nikki, what is it? He said, Daddy, have you noticed, I used to be a whiner. And have you
但她以以下方式创立了积极心理学。她刚过完五岁生日，大约是在花园里发生这件事前两周。我们在一起在花园里，我在除草。尼基玩得很开心。她又唱又跳，把杂草扔向空中。我冲她大喊，我说：“去干活，尼基，该死。我们在除草。”尼基走开了。她回来后说：“爸爸，我能跟你谈谈吗？”我说：“当然，尼基，什么事？”她说：“爸爸，你注意到了吗？我以前是个爱抱怨的人。你注意到了吗？”
noticed that since my fifth birthday, I haven't whined once? I said, oh, yeah. Yeah, Nikki, that's right. He says, well, Daddy, on my fifth birthday, I decided that I wasn't going to whine anymore. And that was the hardest thing I've ever done. And if I can stop whining, you can stop being such a grouch. And she hit the nail on the head. In three different ways, all of a sudden, I realized three different things. First, that she was right and that I was a grouch. And indeed, what I thought, what I was so proud about was my ability to see what was wrong with everything.
“自从我五岁生日以来，我一次都没抱怨过？”我说：“哦，是的。是的，尼基，没错。”她说：“嗯，爸爸，在我五岁生日那天，我决定我再也不抱怨了。那是我做过的最难的事情。如果我能停止抱怨，你也能停止做一个脾气暴躁的人。”她一针见血。突然之间，我意识到了三件事。首先，她是对的，我确实是个脾气暴躁的人。事实上，我引以为豪的是我能看出每件事有什么问题。
And I realized for the first time, maybe any success I had in life was not because of being a pessimist and a grouch and a critic, but maybe it was because I could sometimes see what was right rather than what was wrong. And I decided to change. And indeed, I have. I measure these things not only in the general population, but in myself. So the first thing was, Nikki was right, and I was a grouch, and maybe being a grouch really got in the way of doing what I wanted in life. And the second thing I realized was that my theory of child rearing was wrong. So my theory of child rearing in education was remedial.
我第一次意识到，也许我在生活中取得的任何成功，并不是因为我是一个悲观主义者、一个脾气暴躁的人和一个批评家，而是因为我有时能看到什么是对的，而不是什么是错的。我决定改变。事实上，我确实改变了。我不仅在普通人群中衡量这些东西，也在我自己身上衡量。所以第一件事是，尼基是对的，我确实是个脾气暴躁的人，也许这种脾气真的阻碍了我做我想做的事。第二件事我意识到的是，我的育儿理论是错误的。所以我的育儿和教育理论是补救性的。
It basically said that what our job as teachers and parents to do was to find out what our kids were doing wrong and correct them. And somehow if we corrected all of their errors, we get an exemplary child. Well, it struck me that that's nonsense. What you get then is a child that's not doing anything wrong. But your job as a parent and a teacher is to find out what the kid does right. what they're strong at. And what I saw on Nikki now was her ability to talk sense to adults and to identify that strength and to get your child or your or your student to live their life around what they do well, not to spend their life avoiding what they do badly. So that was the second
它基本上说，我们作为老师和父母的工作是找出孩子们做错了什么并纠正他们。如果纠正了他们所有的错误，我们就能得到一个模范孩子。嗯，这让我觉得那是胡扯。你得到的是一个什么错都不犯的孩子。但你作为父母和老师的工作是找出孩子做对了什么，他们擅长什么。我现在在尼基身上看到的是她与成年人讲道理的能力，识别那种优势，并让你的孩子或学生围绕他们擅长的事情生活，而不是花一生去避免他们做得不好的事情。所以那是第二
thing I learned. And I changed my child rearing and my teaching. My teaching used to to be all full of red marks on papers. And now it's full of blue marks which says, hey, that's a really perfect sentence. You got that word exactly right. And the third thing I realized was about psychology, about APA, for that matter. That psychology had been all about what was wrong, pathology, weakness, the things that were going wrong in the world. Indeed, I had worked on that for 30 years, depression, schizophrenia, drug addiction, suicide, and the like. But that's only half the battle.
件事我学到的。我改变了我的育儿和教学方式。我的教学过去总是满篇红叉。现在满篇都是蓝色的标记，上面写着：“嘿，那是一个非常完美的句子。你那个词用得太准了。”第三件事我意识到的是关于心理学，关于APA。心理学一直关注的是什么是错的，病理学、弱点、世界上正在出错的事情。事实上，我已经研究了30年，抑郁症、精神分裂症、药物成瘾、自杀等等。但这只是战斗的一半。
The other half of the battle is recognizing what's going well in life and building it and leading your life around it. So it occurred to me in that epiphany that there could be a movement, positive psychology, whose mission in life would be to recognize not just the troubles and do something about it, not just what cripples life, but what makes life worth living and teaches people the skills that make life worth living. From that, I think you've distilled your research into positive psychology into something that you call the perma model. What is that? So once you decide that you want to work on well-being and you want to work on what enables a good life as opposed to what cripples life, you essentially need the opposite of DSM. You need a definition of the sanities, not just the definition of the crazinesses.
战斗的另一半是认识到生活中什么是顺利的，并建立它，围绕它来引导你的生活。所以在那个顿悟中，我想到可以有一场运动，即积极心理学，其人生使命不仅是识别麻烦并采取行动，不仅是关注什么摧毁了生活，而是关注什么让生活值得过，并教给人们让生活值得过的技能。由此，我想你已经把你的积极心理学研究提炼成了你称之为“PERMA模型”的东西。那是什么？所以一旦你决定要致力于幸福，并致力于什么能使生活美好而不是什么摧毁生活，你本质上就需要DSM的对立面。你需要一个关于“理智”的定义，而不仅仅是关于“疯狂”的定义。
And so what are the elements, what are the pillars of a good life? And Perma says there are five of them. There are five things that non-suffering free people choose. The first is P, positive emotion, being happy, feeling good, high subjective well-being. The second is E, engagement, being one with the music, being completely wrapped up in your worker with someone, you love, and it's always my hope when I'm lecturing that the people who are listening to this are at E. They're completely engaged. We find, by the way, that about 60% of you are in E right now. The other 40% of you are having sexual fantasies. Turned out. That's okay, I guess.
那么，美好生活的要素、支柱是什么？PERMA说有五个。有五件事是无痛苦的自由人会选择的。第一个是P，积极情绪（Positive emotion），快乐，感觉良好，高主观幸福感。第二个是E，投入（Engagement），与音乐融为一体，完全沉浸在你的工作中或与你爱的人在一起，我讲课时总是希望听众处于E状态。他们完全投入。顺便说一句，我们发现你们中大约60%的人现在处于E状态。另外40%的人正在进行性幻想。结果证明。我想那也没关系。
R, P-E-R is good relationships. So people pursue relationships. We're not only individuals, but we're hive creatures. We're like the bees and the wasps and the termites. We want to be part of something. And that leads to M, which is meaning in life. And that's meaning and purpose, latching on to something that you believe in, that's larger than you, that you can belong to and serve.
R，P-E-R是良好的人际关系（Relationships）。所以人们追求人际关系。我们不仅是个人，我们还是蜂巢生物。我们就像蜜蜂、黄蜂和白蚁。我们想成为某件事的一部分。这导致了M，即生活中的意义（Meaning）。这就是意义和目的，抓住你相信的、比你更大的东西，你可以属于它并为之服务。
That's what meaning is. And finally, there's A, achievement. accomplishment, mastery, and competence. So for me, the ingredients of a positive life come down to a dashboard of perma. How much positive emotion, how much engagement, how good are your relationships, how much meaning do you have in life, and how much accomplishment do you have in life? Those are the five elements of positive psychology for me. Over the past year or so, I've talked several psychologists on this podcast about how the pandemic has been a giant natural experiment for them. It's led to research in areas as varied as telework, boredom, ritual, things like that.
这就是意义所在。最后是A，成就（Achievement）。成就、掌控和能力。所以对我来说，积极生活的要素归结为PERMA仪表盘。多少积极情绪，多少投入，人际关系有多好，生活中多少意义，以及生活中多少成就？这就是我心目中积极心理学的五个要素。在过去一年左右的时间里，我在这档播客中与几位心理学家谈论了疫情如何成为他们的一场巨大的自然实验。它导致了远程办公、无聊、仪式等各个领域的研究。
I noticed on the Penn Positive Psychology Center website that there's a link to a COVID-19 study. What are you looking at and what are you hoping to learn? Well, I'm not sure what you're referring to here, Kim. So we have a website. called Authentic Happiness.org. And about 2,000 people, new people a day come to it, and they take the tests on it. So we have across the whole pandemic, a naturally occurring experiment in which we're able to look at increases and decreases in well-being and strengths in depression and anxiety. And so we will eventually try to put this all together, very large groups of people from
我注意到宾大积极心理学中心网站上有一个关于COVID-19研究的链接。你们在关注什么，希望学到什么？嗯，我不确定你指的是什么，金。所以我们有一个网站，叫做Authentic Happiness.org。每天大约有2000名新用户访问它，并进行测试。所以我们在整个疫情期间，有一个自然发生的实验，使我们能够观察幸福感和优势在抑郁和焦虑方面的增加和减少。所以我们最终会尝试把这一切放在一起，来自非常大的人群
and ask the question about the course of the pandemic. And this allows us to predict things like who gets infection, who recovers rapidly and the like. But I'm not ready to discuss any data yet at this point. Sure, yeah. We're still in the middle of this. Yeah. But we've got a very good database. And this is something you were looking at anyway.
并询问关于疫情进程的问题。这使我们能够预测谁会感染，谁恢复得快等等。但我现在还没准备好讨论任何数据。当然，是的。我们还处于中间阶段。是的。但我们有一个非常好的数据库。这是你无论如何都会关注的事情。
And now because of the pandemic, you're seeing that you're going to be asking, evaluating. We look at it all the time. So, for example, this was going on before 9-11. And so we had hundreds of people at that time, now thousands coming every day. And what we found after 9-11, we looked for the next three months at changes in the strengths. And what we found in the United States was that hope, love and faith increased forgiveness over the next three months in America, but not in any other country. And then by about three months later, that had gone back to baseline. So events like
现在因为疫情，你看到你将要询问、评估。我们一直都在看。例如，这在9-11之前就在进行。所以当时我们有数百人，现在每天有数千人来。9-11之后，我们在接下来的三个月里观察了优势的变化。我们在美国发现，希望、爱和信仰在接下来的三个月里在美国增加了宽恕，但在其他任何国家都没有。然后大约三个月后，它又回到了基线。所以像
9-11, and we haven't yet looked for the pandemic, actually increase strengths like hope and love. But the increases don't necessarily endure, apparently. And they don't last. Yeah. Yeah. And that's very, very large numbers of people. So these are, these are pretty reliable statistics. So we've, for more than 20 years now, been mapping the world or the English-speaking world that comes every day to the website and takes questionnaires. Changing gears a little bit. Positive. psychology has become accepted within the discipline over the last several decades, but it's also inspired some pushback. Where I work at APA, we answer a lot of calls from reporters. And recently, we fielded a number on toxic positivity. The idea that feeling forced to try to be happy and
9-11这样的事件——我们还没有观察疫情，实际上增加了希望和爱这样的优势。但这些增加并不一定会持续，显然。它们不会持久。是的。是的。而且那是非常非常多的人。所以这些是相当可靠的统计数据。所以我们已经有20多年在绘制世界，或者说每天来到网站并填写问卷的英语世界。换个话题。积极心理学在过去几十年里在学科内得到了认可，但也引发了一些反弹。我在APA工作，我们接听很多记者的电话。最近，我们处理了一些关于“有毒的积极性”的电话。那种认为被迫试图快乐和
positive all the time can actually be bad for our well-being. What are your thoughts on this? Yeah, I think trying to force anyone to do something is bad for our well-being. And so trying to force people to be positive can be toxic. So one has to weigh the consequences of becoming more positive, that is, of going through the work of disputing your most pessimistic thoughts, which is not easy, particularly during a pandemic, against its benefits, which are things like reemployment, recovery, and resilience. So people who don't, who adopt optimism in good cheer naturally are very lucky. People like me who have to learn optimism run into the danger of, well, this is a task
一直保持积极实际上可能对我们的幸福有害的想法。你对此有什么看法？是的，我认为强迫任何人做任何事对我们的幸福都是有害的。所以试图强迫人们变得积极可能是“有毒的”。因此，一个人必须权衡变得更积极的后果，即通过反驳你最悲观的想法（这并不容易，特别是在疫情期间）所付出的努力，与它的好处（如重新就业、恢复和韧性）进行权衡。所以那些自然而然地采取乐观和开朗态度的人非常幸运。像我这样必须学习乐观的人会面临这样的危险：嗯，这是一项任务，
and this is difficult. And there's a literature on this. And so, for example, one of the reliable exercises in positive psychology is to do acts of kindness for other people. And indeed, we find that if you're assigned to do a random act of kindness next Wednesday, and you do it, your depression goes down and your life satisfaction. goes up. But if you're assigned to do it every day, then you get the reverse effect. So you have to find a way not to overtax people. And so that's my reaction to the notion. But on the whole, I think the benefits of learning optimism and learning perma quite outweigh the drawbacks. But it's a clinical skill. And you have to do it with a light touch.
这很困难。关于这一点有文献记载。例如，积极心理学中可靠的练习之一是为他人做善事。确实，我们发现如果你被分配在下周三做一件随机的善事，并且你做了，你的抑郁感会下降，生活满意度会上升。但如果你被分配每天都做，那么你就会得到相反的效果。所以你必须找到一种不让人们负担过重的方法。这就是我对这个概念的反应。但总的来说，我认为学习乐观和学习PERMA的好处远大于弊端。但这是一种临床技能。你必须以轻柔的方式去做，
and at the right time, and you can't overdo it. Another criticism I've seen is that positive psychology puts the onus for human flourishing too much on the individual and that it takes attention away from some of the societal factors such as racism and poverty that limit people's ability to live a meaningful life. Is that a legitimate critique? Yeah, this is a very important kind of question. And legitimate is the wrong word, but here's the way I think about it. If you're interested in the world and you want a better world, what is the right balance between building individual happiness and building a collective happiness in the world?
在正确的时间，而且你不能做得过火。我看到的另一个批评是，积极心理学把人类蓬勃发展的责任过多地放在了个人身上，它分散了人们对一些社会因素（如种族主义和贫困）的关注，这些因素限制了人们过上有意义生活的能力。这是一个合理的批评吗？是的，这是一个非常重要的问题。而且“合理”这个词用得不对，但我对它的看法是这样的。如果你对世界感兴趣，并且想要一个更好的世界，在建立个人幸福和建立世界集体幸福之间，什么是正确的平衡？
And these are often in tension with one another. And so, for example, I just gave a lecture to Nordic young students on this issue. And many of them want to become politicians and change the basic things that are wrong with Nordic government. And others of them want to become psychologists and change individuals. And Aristotle told us, by the way, that the two most noble professions were teaching in politics. Well, politics, I think, is about changing the institutions that have gone wrong. And I'm all for that. And psychology is by and large about changing the minds, the thinking of individuals.
这些往往是相互冲突的。例如，我刚刚就这个问题给北欧的年轻学生做了一次讲座。他们中的许多人想成为政治家，改变北欧政府中基本的错误。而其他人想成为心理学家，改变个人。顺便说一句，亚里士多德告诉我们，最崇高的两个职业是教学和政治。嗯，我认为政治是关于改变那些出错的制度。我完全支持这一点。而心理学大体上是关于改变思想，改变个人的思维。
Now, you can do both. Some heads do it better than others. So I'm not a politician. I'm better at helping individuals find happiness. The art of politics is helping the society find happiness. And these two marry pretty well. They're not intention. So let me give you an example of something that I work on.
现在，你可以两者兼顾。有些头脑比其他人做得更好。所以我不是政治家。我更擅长帮助个人找到幸福。政治的艺术是帮助社会找到幸福。这两者结合得很好。它们并不冲突。所以让我给你举一个我正在研究的例子。
So I'm interested in the question of whether or not politically government should measure GDP or happiness in a culture. So is the goal of good government more wealth, which is what my economist friends tell me, or is it more happiness? Okay. So that's an important political issue. And politicians argue about this. It's a major issue in England right now, a major issue in New Zealand, major issue in the Emirates. Shouldn't we study both? Don't they go hand in hand?
我对政府在政治上应该衡量GDP还是文化幸福感这个问题很感兴趣。那么，好的政府的目标是更多的财富——这是我的经济学家朋友告诉我的——还是更多的幸福？好吧，这是一个重要的政治议题。政客们对此争论不休。这目前在英国、新西兰和阿联酋都是一个重大议题。我们不应该两者都研究吗？它们不是相辅相成的吗？
Yes. And so what the politicians do is they ask which of these things should we matter? What the psychologist says is, well, let's work on good measures of happiness. And indeed, that complements the political life. So to think there's a tension between the psychology of improving happiness individuals and the psychology of improving a society is often a strong man. And by the way, it's very important within positive psychology that most of the exercises that actually work and produce more individual happiness are exercises like helping another person.
是的。政客们所做的是询问我们应该重视哪一个。心理学家所说的是，好吧，让我们致力于制定好的幸福衡量标准。事实上，这与政治生活是互补的。因此，认为改善个人幸福的心理学与改善社会的心理学之间存在矛盾，往往是一种稻草人谬误。顺便说一句，在积极心理学中非常重要的一点是，大多数真正有效并能产生更多个人幸福感的练习，都是像帮助他人这样的练习。
So the single most effective antidepressant short exercise we have is if you're depressed right now, turn this blog off, go out, find someone who needs help and help them. That's the single best antidepressant we know. So very often, Chris Peterson's theme, Other People Matter, as the heart of positive psychology, is indeed at the heart of building individual. happiness as well. So I think there's a strong man here. I think we can both build individual happiness and we can build the best institutions and correct the institutions that have gone wrong in our society. After all these years of studying positive psychology, what's left? Are there still some unanswered questions? Well, there's a huge one, and it's the one I'm working on now. So I've been off a lot more than I can chew, Kim, but let me tell you what I've been writing for the last couple of years, and it will probably go on for a few more years.
因此，我们拥有的最有效的抗抑郁短期练习是：如果你现在感到沮丧，关掉这个博客，走出去，找到一个需要帮助的人并帮助他们。这是我们所知的最有效的抗抑郁药。所以，克里斯·彼得森的主题“他人很重要”作为积极心理学的核心，确实也是建立个人幸福的核心。所以我认为这里存在一个稻草人谬误。我认为我们既可以建立个人幸福，也可以建立最好的制度，并纠正我们社会中已经出错的制度。在研究了这么多年的积极心理学之后，还剩下什么？还有未解的问题吗？嗯，有一个巨大的问题，这也是我现在正在研究的问题。金，我承担的任务比我能处理的要多得多，但让我告诉你我过去几年一直在写的东西，这可能还会持续几年。
The theme of my life's work has been agency. And for me, agency has three components. The first is what Al Bandura called self-efficacy, efficacy. and that's the belief I can achieve a goal. The second element of agency is optimism and future-mindedness, that I can achieve this goal well into the future. And the third element of agency is imagination. And that's the belief that there are a whole lot of good goals,
我毕生工作的核心主题是能动性。对我来说，能动性有三个组成部分。第一是阿尔·班杜拉所说的自我效能感，即我相信我能实现目标。能动性的第二个要素是乐观和未来导向，即我相信我能在遥远的未来实现这个目标。能动性的第三个要素是想象力。即相信有许多好的目标，
a whole lot of scenarios that I can achieve well into the future. So I've asked the question, what is the world history of agency? And the hypothesis is that when societies and religions and epochs are highly agentic, that they have beliefs in human efficacy, optimism, and imagination, that's when progress occurs. And by progress, by the way, this is not an arbitrary term. I mean progress in thinking, progress in technology, progress in medicine, progress in the arts,
有许多场景是我在遥远的未来可以实现的。所以我提出了一个问题：能动性的世界历史是什么？假设是，当社会、宗教和时代具有高度能动性时，即它们相信人类的效能、乐观和想象力时，进步就会发生。顺便说一句，进步并不是一个随意的术语。我指的是思想的进步、技术的进步、医学的进步、艺术的进步，
progress in literature, progress in the quality of human life, and progress in human freedom. So when in history does progress occur? And the hypothesis is that when the culture believes in agency, that's when progress occurs. when the culture, when the religion believes in lack of agency, that's when stagnation occurs. And so what I'm doing is going through human history from hunter, fishers, and gatherers up in the West and in China trying to measure the culture's belief in human agency and progress. And just for example, I've just published a paper on Greco-Roman thought and agency. And basically, if you go back to the Iliad, the Iliad, the gods have it all, and there's no human agency.
文学的进步、人类生活质量的进步以及人类自由的进步。那么历史上什么时候会出现进步呢？假设是，当文化相信能动性时，进步就会发生；当文化或宗教相信缺乏能动性时，停滞就会发生。所以我正在做的是梳理从狩猎、捕鱼和采集者到西方和中国的人类历史，试图衡量文化对人类能动性和进步的信仰。举个例子，我刚刚发表了一篇关于希腊罗马思想与能动性的论文。基本上，如果你回到《伊利亚特》，在《伊利亚特》中，神拥有这一切，而没有人类的能动性。
By the Odyssey, humans start to have it. And by the golden age of Greek philosophy, it's hugely agentic. It's optimistic, it's efficacious and an imaginative. And to map into that trend, there's enormous progress in Greco-Roman area. And this goes on until about 380 AD and when Rome is falling apart. And at the time, the early Christian philosophers are enormously agentic. And St. Augustine comes along in 384 and says, no, it's all God's agency. If you happen to do something good, happen to avoid evil, it's entirely God's grace.
到了《奥德赛》，人类开始拥有能动性。到了希腊哲学的黄金时代，它具有极强的能动性。它是乐观的、高效的和富有想象力的。为了映射这一趋势，希腊罗马地区取得了巨大的进步。这种情况一直持续到公元380年左右，当时罗马正在分崩离析。那时，早期的基督教哲学家具有极强的能动性。圣奥古斯丁在384年出现并说，不，一切都是上帝的能动性。如果你碰巧做了一件好事，碰巧避免了邪恶，那完全是上帝的恩典。
And it is my view that Augustine's view of Christianity, which becomes Catholic doctrine for almost a thousand years, produces the stagnation of the Middle Ages. So, and indeed, my colleagues in China have just done the same analysis for Chinese culture through the Greco-Roman period. And again, the same kind of things occur. So what I'm working on right now, and for me, the big question in positive psychology, is this just a peculiar Western idea of the 21st century in which it's a good idea to be positive? or is there a human history of this? And I think there is a human history.
我的观点是，奥古斯丁的基督教观——它在近一千年里成为了天主教教义——导致了中世纪的停滞。事实上，我在中国的同事刚刚对中国文化在希腊罗马时期的表现进行了同样的分析。同样，也出现了类似的情况。所以我现在正在研究的，对我来说是积极心理学中的大问题，是：这只是21世纪西方的一种奇特想法，即积极是一种好主意吗？还是说这有人类历史的渊源？我认为确实有人类历史的渊源。
It translates into agency. And I think it's the controlling engine of human progress. And just to say one more thing, Kim, about what I'm working on here. Many different fields have tried to do the history of the world. And so the greatest one recently is Jared Diamond, in which Diamond basically argues that ecology is at the center of human progress. And what I'm trying to do right now is to say, no, the center of human progress is a mental process called agency. It's that agency that has produced human progress.
它转化为能动性。我认为它是人类进步的控制引擎。金，关于我正在研究的内容，我还要再说一点。许多不同的领域都试图撰写世界历史。最近最伟大的一部是贾雷德·戴蒙德的作品，戴蒙德基本上认为生态是人类进步的核心。而我现在试图做的是说，不，人类进步的核心是一种称为能动性的心理过程。正是这种能动性产生了人类的进步。
So I want to do for psychology what Jared Diamond did for ecology. But one of the important differences, if you believe just Diamond, theory, it doesn't leave you with any interventions for children and for the future. So we can't change the climate very much. We can't change the direction in which the rivers flow. But we can change the belief in agency. That sounds like an absolutely astonishing project, and I look forward to seeing you complete that. It sounds like a lifetime of work. My hat is off to you, Dr. Seligman. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Seligman. You've given our listeners a great deal of good information to think about and to work on things that they can
所以我想为心理学做贾雷德·戴蒙德为生态学所做的事情。但一个重要的区别是，如果你只相信戴蒙德的理论，它不会给你留下任何针对儿童和未来的干预措施。我们无法改变气候，我们无法改变河流流动的方向。但我们可以改变对能动性的信仰。这听起来是一个绝对令人惊叹的项目，我期待看到你完成它。这听起来是一生的工作。我向你致敬，塞利格曼博士。感谢你今天加入我们，塞利格曼博士。你为我们的听众提供了大量有益的信息，让他们思考并付诸实践，
take into their lives and act upon. Oh, thanks for having me, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kund Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
将这些融入他们的生活并采取行动。哦，谢谢你邀请我，金。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·昆德。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。